[Musique]
bonsoir à tout le monde
oui merci à cette intro pour cette
introduction j'ai tué trois vies d'abord
j'étais prêtre catholique pendant douze
ans je me suis marié
forcément je lui chercher un autre
travail et je me suis retrouvé comme par
hasard parmi les douze fou qui
conseillait jacques delors et nous avons
en quelques années tous les jours y
avait nouvelles idées nous avons
construit l'europe d'hier celle des
traités qui était centre gauche qui
n'est pas du tout la même que celle qui
fonctionne aujourd'hui
alors peut-être qu'on peut regarder la
première dia mon message
moi ça fait presque 30 ans 25 ans que
j'annonce le nouveau paradigme sur
lequel on avait travaillé avec jacques
delors et je m'excuse d'être positif
mais j'ai l'impression qu'une partie de
la jeune génération
et comme met dedans et au fond je le dis
mais thomas ce qu'une d'harvard de
beille il avait raison il faut trente
ans il faut 25 ans la génération z dont
vous faites partie en partie et dans ces
nouvelles valeurs je dirais même que le
disque dur de certains jeunes et déjà
adapté au nouveau parti dont il suffit
de faire tourner le disque est donc mon
message au début de cette conférence et
vous ayez confiance en votre disque dur
ayez confiance en votre disque dur
en vo intuition profonde suivant
puis on s'est mis d'accord parce que moi
j'aime pas le petit
alors le changement de paradigme c'est
un énorme iceberg et la plupart de
liesberg est en dessous du feu en
dessous de l'offre de l'eau ça veut dire
y'a pas le débat on n'en parle pas dans
la presse on n'en parle jamais à
personne je vais aller vite
[Musique]
revenons à liesberg
le moteur le changement de paradigme il
ya un moteur extrêmement puissant et
c'est quoi tout le monde te comprends
tout le citoyen du monde le comprenne
nous avons créé une civilisation qui a
inventé deux possibilités de suicide
collectif
la guerre nucléaire nous avons encore
dix sept fois la possibilité de faire
sauter la terre ça fait dix-sept fois de
trop tout le monde sait ça et la seconde
c'est une croissance infinie dans un
monde fini tout le monde comprend que
c'est pas possible
la bonne nouvelle c'est qu'ils semblent
que l'inconscient collectif de
l'humanité est certainement la jeune
génération est en train au niveau des
tripes de passer devant leur demeure à
20 heures de vie nous sommes en train de
décider collectivement que nous ne
voulons pas que l'humanité
collapse ça c'est le moteur du
changement de parti et comme disait très
bien willis herman qui était un des
responsables du stanford research
institute
il ya 20 ans il disait nous sommes dans
un changement que personne ne peut
arrêter ni les puissances militaires les
puissances économiques mais les
puissances politiques parce que c'est un
changement of de hime jazz off 2d des
concepts de base des valeurs de base de
notre civilisation
le moteur c'est ça il y à l'esprit qui
vient avec
nous avons 10 et max weber désenchanté
le monde la modernité en en faisant tout
rationnel en en faisant dans notre
cerveau abstraction de tout ce qui n'est
pas rationnelle à désenchanter le monde
et nous sommes en chemin de rien je sais
ce que je vous souhaite c'est ce que je
me serais et ceci me permet d'ajouter
quelque chose dans mon corps et comme je
crois que je suis dans une quatrième
phase de ma vie au delà de toute la
biologie que j'ai appris je suis en
train de découvrir le chemin de l'être
et je suis en train de réenchanter ma
vision de la vie et de la mort bien
on va rester dans les bacs encore
quelques minutes vous comprenez bien le
deuxième niveau
il est évident qu'avec les valeurs
command control et conquête du
matriarcat qu'ils ont permis de faire
des découvertes technologiques
extraordinaire d'aller jusqu'à la lune
vous comprenez bien qu'avec ses valeurs
on ne sait pas planifié une société
soutenable
donc il faut ajouter des nouvelles
valeurs playing de connexion avec la
nature de riz connexion avec son
intériorité de de respect de
d'intelligence collective
tout ça est nouveau et donc la bonne
nouvelle c'est que le camion du
patriarcat continue à écraser des
millions de femmes dans le monde mais le
moteur le moteur du patriarcat la
justification théorique du patriarcat
être en train d'avoir des premières raté
je vous donne un exemple si je suis
interview interviewé à antenne 2 ça
m'étonnerait et que je dis devant tout
le monde mais evidian évidemment les
femmes sont moins intelligentes ou moins
capables ou moins doué que les hommes
je me sens sortir ça veut dire que
certaines choses qu'on disait il ya 20
ans vers 30 ans il ya 40 ans ne sont
plus acceptés aujourd'hui ça c'est le
début des premières ratés du moteur qui
fait marcher le temps la transe
modernité alors nous sommes en train de
sortir de la modernité analytique
rationnelle cogito matérialiste
mécaniste et patriarcat et comme dit
très bien être garnerin plus le
changement de civilisation avance moins
nous universités sont capables de le
penser pourquoi parce que nos
universités sont programmées en petite
boîte et donc y'a pas moyen de penser le
changement parce que chacun est dans sa
boîte
donc il ya personne qui est méchant
c'est systémique la transe modernité
retenait si vous retenez deux idées sur
la trans modernité c'est le retour de
l'éthique comme un des conférenciers
viens de l'expliquer le retour de
l'éthique et du sens et maintenant nous
allons nous pencher sur le paradigme
économique
alors nous partons l'économie s'est créé
de la valeur de notre comprends ça le
processus de création de valeur change
complètement
quel est le processus de création de
valeur agricole
j'ai besoin d'un champ j'ai besoin de
semences par mon 200 tours de préférence
je sème 100 kg et je moissonne 1000 kg
avec 700 kg je vais marcher et je vends
mon grain je crée de la valeur agricole
je reviens et je fais marcher ma famille
avec ce que j'ai gagné
comment est ce que je crée de la valeur
industrielle valeurs industrielles
suppose d'abord un bloc d'acier des
pièces détachées et puis une usine usine
c'est l'outil de production laudine
coûte cher donc je dois créer une bourse
etc
j'ai besoin de beaucoup de capital
monsieur marx avait compris que l'ère
industrielle industriels étaient l'ère
capitaliste
pourquoi parce qu'il faut du capital sur
leur capital mais non l'économie
matérielle
je suis monsieur sur berg et je crée
facebook
j'ai une idée je l'appliqué à une
connaissance et je crée un concept donc
j'applique de la connaissance à la
connaissance pour créer de la
connaissance
cette définition vient de peter de recul
et quand même le tout grand spécialiste
du management mondiale ça veut dire quoi
il ya plus de chance il ya plus de
semences ya plus du sinn
il ya plus de blocs d'acier il savait
dire une petite production ou est ce
qu'il est ce qu'il est l'outil de
production
il rentre chez lui tous les goûts tous
les soirs l'outil de production
c'est plus l'usiné et à plus moyen
d'être propriétaire du moyen de
production
au revoir marx au revoir le cas toutes
les les conflits du xxème siècle ces
flics on change d'air
ça veut dire aussi que comme chef
d'entreprise dans l'économie matérielle
votre du rhdp complètement différent
c'est quoi
et nous sommes dans le troisième petit
rond le chef d'entreprise favorisent la
créativité en réseau ouvert et en
intelligence collective mais c'est tout
à fait différent c'est un hit so no job
c'est un autre job le le see you
industriels il doit faire en sorte que
ces voitures soient faites de bonne
qualité bon prix on time et à la
satisfaction du client
c'est un job et plus maintenant tout
d'un coup on lui dit mais il faut
favoriser la créativité en réseau et le
pauvre si haut
sa femme lady au petit déjeuner est
d'ailleurs toi comment peux-tu
prophétisé la créativité en réseau
tu ne sais même pas où est ta propre
créativité et donc l'iran ira son boulot
dépité et donkey il se met à faire des
formations
parce qu'il faut se préparer je vais
vous donner encore quelques éléments
j'ai pas le temps de parler de tout une
chose très importante c'est que y'a pas
moyen de vendre
trade la connaissance pourquoi parce que
je la gardais mon cerveau si je vous
vends une volvo
vous avez la volvo mais vous n'avez pas
d'argent donc moi j'ai plus à volvo vous
n'avez plus vous avez la volvo moi je ne
l'est plus mais moi j'ai votre argent et
vous ne l'avez plais bien ici il s'agit
je ne peux faire avec la connaissance
que la partager et je m'excuse de vous
choquer belles connaissances c'est comme
l'amour plus souvent partagés en réseau
ouvert
plus vous en avez c'est choquant mais
c'est choquant on n'est pas préparé à ça
c'est choquant quand même dans une piste
ne school commencé à parler d'amour et
de et de schering d'économie du partage
pourquoi est ce qu'on parle que tout le
monde parle d'économie du partage mais
c'est parce qu'on ne sait pas faire
autre chose avec la connaissance ont
probablement qu'on va garder les brevets
pour la production industrielle parce
qu'un brevet est liée à une chose
comment voulez-vous breveté la
connaissance je crois qu'on va vers
l'open source
y'a pas moyen de faire autrement
les stratégies à deux je voudrais dire
une chose
mesdames soyez consciente que dans cette
nouvelle économie
on travaille en réseau d'accords est
ouvert réseau apprenant d'intelligence
collective mais je rate ma femme elle
travaille en réseau depuis toujours
tandis que moi j'ai été formé dans
l'université dans des réseaux de pouvoir
verticaux et donc moi je dois me des des
conditionné 2 mai formation est sûre ce
temps là ma femme el hadjar est résolu
tous les problèmes en réseau et donc
qu'est ce qu'on constate c'est que les
femmes sont deux fois plus pas toutes
les femmes
les femmes sont deux fois plus efficace
dans cette nouvelle économie
allez-y madame et les entreprises qui
ont compris ça met des femmes y compris
au conseil d'administration à des
postes-clés l'entreprise pas parce qu'on
est féministe on s'en fout c'est pour
faire avancer l'entreprise
alors il ya encore deux bonnes nouvelles
et puis je m'arrête la première c'est
que la croissance
vous allez sur le web vous fait économie
de la connaissance aux 20 millions
d'entrées mais vous en foutez du million
la recrue la quantité vous en foutez
c'est la qualité vous cherchez et donc
nous sommes en train dans les
entreprises de passer en silence une
croissance quantitative à une croissance
qualitative et la bonne nouvelle c'est
que la croissance qualitative les
soutenable ouah
ça c'est une bonne nouvelle et la
dernière ses clients pas moyen d'éviter
la transparence et l'éthique ton
entreprise devient un château de christ
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]